wir hatten ja jetzt den neunten reise
gar nicht so lange her und neunter
europatag was ist an diesem neunten mal
passiert an diesem neunten mal ist
passiert dass die sogenannte
zukunftskonferenz der europäischen union
zu ende gegangen ist jetzt werden die
meisten zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
davon leider nichts gehört haben aber es
war eine ganz große übung dass die
europäische union über ein jahr lang
bürgerinnen und bürger zur zukunft
europas befragt hatten das war super
moderiert also es war auch random
selection die worten ausgewählt also
wirklich zufallsauswahl von 18 bis 90
dass die leute diskutiert haben und in
verschiedenen bürgerforen in venedig in
dublin und so weiter an die leute
diskutiert und jetzt ist der report
davon vorgebracht worden deswegen hab
ich jetzt europa mitgebracht weil wir
jetzt wissen was die bürger wollen und
das interessante daran ist die bürger
wollen eigentlich mehr als die politiker
dh die bürger wollen zum beispiel dass
die einstimmigkeit wegfällt die bürger
wollen ein soziales europa die bürger
wollen wahrscheinlich sogar das ist
jetzt der neue trend vertragsreform nach
artikel 48 das heißt sie wollen europa
auf dem weg zu einer europäischen
verfassung bringen das heißt wir haben
da auf einmal eine ganz große dynamik
wenn es darum geht wie gestalten mit
diesem zukunft lesen kontinent und ich
wollte dass kurz verknüpft mit dem thema
ukraine wir sind ja nun mal in einem
krieg wir sehen gerade dass es europa
schlecht geht wir sehen dass dieser
krieg massive auswirkungen hat also auf
deutschland zum beispiel auf das soziale
gefälle auf die inflation auf die
benzinpreise und so weiter wir sehen das
aber in allen ländern das heißt wir
müssen fürchten dass dieser krieg
natürlich eigentlich auch zu ja sagen
wir mal verwüstungen in sozialer und in
anderer hinsicht für und natürlich zu zu
anderen und ganz unabhängig von den
bildern aus butter und so hat natürlich
aber was ich sagen wollte ist dass wir
verknüpfen müssen sind eigentlich und
damit höre ich dann auch schon auf die
beiden großen ziele was europa mann sein
sollte wir wollten ja können wir uns
kurz erinnern 1992 politische union
helmut kohl mit ja dieses projekt ist
eigentlich bis heute gescheitert wir
haben keine politische union und die
frage ist jetzt mit dieser
zukunftskonferenz kriegen weil das
projekt noch mal wieder und das zweite
große ding und das ist der ukraine
konflikt was wir wollten zumindest
wollten in den letzten 30 jahren ist die
eurasische friedensordnung ist die
sicherheitsstruktur in europa ist die
rockhal in trier und was wir jetzt
machen unter dem eindruck der natürlich
tragischen bilder dieses
kriegsgeschehens ist natürlich
eigentlich spalten wir diesen kontinent
wieder neu
wir gehen sozusagen alle zurück in die
nato wir beerdigen die europäische
souveränität und die europäische
autonomie wir sagen zwar dass der krieg
wie zu mehr einheit führt und es tut da
irgendwo auch ein bisschen im
energiebereich aber nicht so richtig
viel was aber für mich entscheidend ist
wir spalten eigentlich europa jetzt vom
baltikum runter bis zum schwarzen see
und dahinter ist russland darauf von der
leyen gesagt wir müssen die industrielle
basis russlands abtragen ich glaube das
ist keine putin herr putin wird
irgendwann gehen ich glaube das ist
keine basis für den europäischen
kontinent und deswegen bin ich hier um
zu diskutieren
wann kommen wir in eine diskussion um
das aktuelle tragische kriegsgeschehen
in der ukraine zu verbinden mit einer
politischen diskussion über den
kontinent europa wo wollen wir sein
haben wir noch ambitionen politische
ambition souveränität und diese ganzen
dinge und dann würde ich sagen die
ukraine muss befriedet werden und unter
eine europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
natürlich eine europäische zukunft
bekommen aber dieses abschneiden europas
sozusagen vom osten was jetzt passiert
kann für diesen kontinent nicht
zielführend sein da würde ich direkt die
frage an herrn stegner geben ob wir den
kontinent neu spalten die frau gerade
gesagt ich hoffe dass nicht ich glaube
das ist in der aktuellen situation ist
es schwer zu diskutieren weil wir mitten
im krieg sind mitten in europa das muss
schon sehen und weil wir natürlich jetzt
nicht nur sicherheit mit so haben wir
unsere vorstellungen sicherheit gibt es
noch immer nur mit russland im
augenblick muss man auch über sicherheit
gegen lausanne drehen sowie das geführt
ist ich glaube aber trotzdem hinter
vielen optimistisch ein als sie das am
ende europas ist der kleinste aber der
wohlhabendste von den kontinenten und
wenn ihr mitspielen wollen mit china mit
indien mit brasilien mit amerika dann
wird sich europa zusammentun müssen
haben wir keine chance als eine
wirtschaftsunion und keine chance als
eine die sozusagen in nationalismus
zurückfällt sondern haben wir nur dann
eine chance wenn wir mit einer stimme
sprechen das bedeutet aber dass wir auf
der einen seite gegenüber den diktaturen
klar auftreten das geschieht auch aber
das natürlich mit eigenen reihen auch
nicht das dulden was wir nicht dulden
dürfen dass in polen die unabhängige
gerichtsbarkeit abgeschafft wird das in
ungarn die fast auf einen dass wir dem
erdogan vor
reden halten wieder sein müssen aber
selber und haben bestimmte nicht heißt
die demokratien sind extrem gefordert
dass die werte für die wir stehen das
die auch gelebt werden ist die stadt
finden die jungen leute meine
erfahrungen die die spaltung ist nicht
mehr erlebt haben
mauer und stacheldraht und all diese
dinge die sind gewohnt zu heißen die wir
brauchen keine pässe die leben und in
frieden mit ihren nachbarn die haben
nichts gegen ihre nachbarn die paar von
den könnten mehr polnisch oder
französisch lernen da kann man noch
lange arbeiten aber im kern jedenfalls
ist dieses friedliche wohlhabende europa
was wir genossen haben über viele
jahrzehnte das muss verteidigt ausgebaut
werden sonst werden wir unseren stand
nämlich verlieren und das ist der punkt
an dem wir momentan ein bisschen unter
druck durch den krieg aber ich glaube
nicht dass es dauer verloren also ich
finde das hier ein tolles theorie
gebilde ich fürchte nur dass die zeit
für solche diskussion im augenblick
überhaupt nicht reifes dass sie auch in
der öffentlichkeit darüber nicht
diskutieren können jedenfalls nicht mit
dem normalbürger der hat ganz andere
sorgen im augenblick wie gefährdet es
eigentlich der rest europas durch diese
russische aggression
führt er den imperialismus immer weiter
was tun wir und dann erleben wir ja
ohnehin eine andere bewegung das in
europa wir weit entfernt sind von
ursprünglichen ideen einer politischen
einheit wir sind ja dabei dass immer
mehr staaten in der gefahr sind wieder
zu nationalstaaten abzurutschen in stark
autoritäre züge
damit meine ich jetzt nicht ungarn und
orban sollte ich meine frankreich meiner
auch italien das ist nicht
sicher dass da nicht herrn salvini oder
jedenfalls seine läger wieder an die
macht kommt in frankreich wissen wir
nicht was bei den parlamentswahlen was
hier entweder gibt es dann rechts
rutscht oder vielleicht linksruck beides
nicht unbedingt demokratie fördern oder
so wie wir es verstehen und in beiden
ländern sind das gleichzeitig europa
skeptiker die einige europa nicht wollen
marine le pen genauso wie mir auch schon
in frankreich und salvini und die
wir haben sie noch die freunde der von
herrn konnte ja genau ich
bestelle die sind ja auch nicht
sonderlich europa orientiert also ich
wir haben so viel will ich sagen
hausaufgaben im auge zu leisten dass
glaube jede idee die völlig berechtigt
wie kann die zukunft eines weiter
geeinten europas eigentlich aus in dem
augenblick
nicht perfekt weil das andere viel
wichtiger leute die frage ist sowas ist
so wichtiger ist ja immer so eine
wechselbewegung mehr was ich im ziel ist
sie haben ihre analyse ist ja perfekt
das heißt wir haben eine innere
zersetzung bewegung also die ganzen
populismus parteien und so weiter in
europa und diese versetzung
nach gerade gefährlich zu sein ist
völlig richtig dass wir nicht mehr nur
von polen oder nur von ungarn reden
sondern eben frankreich und so weiter
wir haben alle gezittert marie le pen
ich saß ja noch habe noch vorgetragen
marine le pen und so weiter italien
großes thema so die innere zersetzung
geht aber einher und das wollte ich eben
sagen mit einem klammergriff was man
früher in diskussion im amerika genannt
hat ja also nur mal ein beispiel wir
haben jetzt die all denen die zuglinie
von belgrad nach budapest wird jetzt von
china gebaut ja und vielleicht baut ja
china dem ist auch die buslinie von
budapest nach stuttgart ja also auf der
anderen seite haben wir jetzt auch durch
coroner natürlich im mittelstand
wirklich probleme in europa bekommen
digitalisierung ist amerika gaffer
amazon usw das heißt wir sind geo
ökonomisch und geostrategisch in so
einer art america klammergriff und mein
plädoyer ist und dann ist die frage wann
mache mir dass sie haben natürlich
völlig recht wir sehen mal so abgelenkt
von allen wichtigen themen ja aber auf
der anderen seite dieser große wurf ich
habe noch viel sagte lohr gearbeitet da
hat man noch von grand prix europa vom
großen europäischen projekten geredet
und deswegen würde ich hier gerne sagen
wir brauchen jetzt mal ein großes
europäisches projekt benehmen und zehn
jahre für den euro war auch zehn jahre
gebraucht aber wir sagen einfach mal bis
2030 oder 32 erstens zweitens drittens
europäische arbeitslosenversicherung
europäisches bürgerstadt tut abschaffung
der einstimmigkeit und so weiter buch
stadien war das aus gucken was die
bürger jetzt auf den tisch gelegt haben
und dann haben wir ein klares ziel vor
augen und dann rocken wir die diskussion
alles klar glauben sie eigentlich bevor
sie am donnerstag wenn sie so etwas
vortragen in ihrer fraktion was sagt die
sind spinnt ihr damals nicht mehr da ist
wäre das spiel sicher
ich bin nicht so skeptisch dass die
europäische idee war eine antwort auf
den zweiten weltkrieg und das in europa
an gericht war das blutigste kontinent
überhaupt jetzt werden wir durch andere
dinge ammann wir sehen was in china
passiert wir ahnen dass das mit dem tram
vielleicht noch nicht ausgestanden ist
das ist ein großes problem ist also
spitze der westlichen welt macht jemand
stand der demokratie auch nicht
akzeptiert das capitol stürmen lässt
wahl nicht akzeptiert das könnte wieder
kommen das heißt europa kann glaube ich
dass wir unseren wohlstand verlieren
wenn wir uns nicht zusammenreißen genau
wir reißen uns aber durchaus zusammen
wir merken bei den dänen bei den finden
bei den schweden die jetzt aus anderen
gründen die kommen ja nicht nur zur nato
sondern die kommen auch ein stück die
dänen haben immer gesagt wir machen das
mit dem euro nicht sondern das heißt bei
uns weiterhin kronen aber wir machen
jeden schritt mit das ist eine
ungefährliche form von nationalismus ist
es wunderbar und national psychologie
funktioniert bestens und alle sind
zufrieden und solche dinge kann man auch
machen abermals sehr punktuell alles
also das ist so das problem aber ich
glaube der gedanken ist schon da das wir
ahnen wir haben auch eine verpflichtung
gegenüber seinen kindern hängen dass er
so bleibt wie wir das haben erleben
dürfen also ist aber jemand gedanken
lesen und gerade und deswegen also ich
fand das ganz interessant ihren einwurf
jetzt ist nicht die zeit dafür ja gerade
jetzt ist eigentlich die breite gerade
solche leidenschaft
richtig und nicht nur so am rande weil
wir die meisten beim europatag waren wir
ja in bonn für die meisten ist so wie
fähnchen und luftballons also so gefühlt
ja das ist aber mehr also europa muss
tatsächlich ja auch hätte ja gar nichts
anfangen letzten richtig aus und haben
nichts gelernt man muss sich trennen von
intellektuell überzeugenden konzeptionen
die man auch in seinen kreisen in seiner
blase wie es heute so schön heißt mut
diskutieren kann ich muss aber bei den
dingen die menschen mitnehmen das ist ja
so ein punkt den die politik immer
weniger vergisst dass man bei 1 sachen
die menschen irgendwie mitnehmen aber
dieses mal habe ich ja wichtiger
gekommen mit dem bürger vorschläge 49
vorschlägen die 300.000 europäischen
bürgerinnen entwickelt haben das heißt
das sind ja die menschen die das gemacht
haben wir das schon richtig aber das ist
doch nicht erst noch nicht mal die
deutsche bevölkerung jetzt fragen sie
die mal ob in der jetzigen zeit wir noch
mehr europa wollen
ja meine vor gericht er hat glaube ich
recht was die fragen denn die vermutlich
das in der situation jetzt aber der
krieg wird ja hoffentlich nicht noch
ganz lange dauern aber es gibt bessere
zeiten dafür aber natürlich nicht
wichtig man muss dann auch mit etwas
überzeugend und mit leidenschaft kommen
das ist für sichere holen das ist eine
gute sache ist und nicht mit diesen
drögen darlegungen die eine wunderbare
politik sprechen uns mit über
intellektualisierung das funktioniert
ich war doch gar nicht drüber nach ob
die fans
ich finde das was sie hören macht der
gesine schwan auch die sagt wir müssen
das mal mit der umfunktionierung unserer
gesellschaft und erfährt sie in die
lausitz diskutiert mit bürgern darüber
die nehmen wir die mit dass sie nicht
gegen die umwandlung und industrie
gesellschaft sind es nicht werden eine
partitur stärker was ich mir als
bürgerin wenn ich eine talkshow und da
sitzen leute und sagen mal wie die
bürger empfinden was die bürger denken
auflegen immer
[Applaus]
ein
ständiges thema und der urlaub voll
bürger
kleiner spalt sie dürfen uns liegen mit
ihrer these